normalement d'ici là ça serait noire de
monde
les scènes mobiles de style and à
l'assomption bouge au rythme des
festivals et des événements de foule de
la planète au fur et à mesure des
mollets quand c'est la science n'arrête
pas de rides mais la coved 19 à stopper
brutalement les 150 remorques ici en
habituellement l'amérique du nord dès
1500 événements prévus on en compte
maintenant qu'une centaine les
opérations de fabrication de scènes
mobiles vendus dans le monde
on tend plus ralentie de moitié la
grande scène que sur la place des
festivals
c'est la remorque que vous voyez là en
position fermée et ce camion immobile
affichant un vestige de la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre qui battait son plein
avant la pandémie
l'entreprise passera de 200 à 120
employés
on voyage beaucoup d'une verra un autre
pilote de rester ici à travailler une
fois de temps en temps à la shop c'est
pas toujours évident on reste vraiment
positif comme qu'on peut voir y ait
quelques festivals qui se passe en
europe avec la distanciation social on
espère que ça s'en vient bientôt aux
états unis et on est très verticale dans
ce qu'on fait on fait commerce de saint
mobiles des clients la conception la
fabrication la déclaration
c'est uniquement la location l'accès
sera complètement arrêté la
diversification des opérations
d'entreprise lui permet donc de survivre
du moins pour le moment
son dirigeant aussi bénéficier de la
subvention salariale d'urgence mais il
demeure inquiet pour la suite
l'aide sera réduite en septembre et le
gouvernement fédéral prévoit y mettre
fin en décembre
il ya un risque de perte d'emploi qu'il
ya un risque de perte d' expertise ils
interpellent le premier ministre
québécois
ironiquement en visite un mois avant le
grand confinement afin qu'il apporte un
soutien pour maintenir le lien d'emploi
est ce qu'on m'en nos gouvernements
c'est considérer que c'est un parterre
de protéger les gens qui travaillent
derrière la scène dans notre industrie
sinon comme bien d'autres entreprises le
retour à la croissance de ce tag line
tardera inévitablement ici matuidi aura
du canada
la ceinture
[Musique]